it's great to welcome to the program
today caleb kane who runs the YouTube
channel Faraday speaks he's involved in
D radicalizing young people who get
involved in the far-right and is
actually the subject of the recent New
York Times article the making of a
YouTube radical by Kevin Roose which has
gotten a lot of attention
Caleb great to talk to you I'm looking
forward to this yeah thank you David and
thank you for having me on so first
things first I mean how did the New York
Times even find you and decide that you
would be the good subject of an article
about radicalization and D
radicalization well when I'm when I
first put the video out I never expected
it to go that viral but what I think
happened was I went to Twitter and I was
basically I was basically trying to
market the video a little bit and I was
talking to a lot of people on there and
just like going through and explaining
old ideas that I had and it seemed like
a lot of people were kind of interested
by that they've never had someone come
out and do that before and at some point
I remember Christian pickle Eenie
messaged me yeah and he was like hey man
are you gonna put out a video in all
this and I'm like yeah and he's like
well let me know when you do my theory
is that they retweeted that stuff and
that's why it got so viral I also shared
it in some gaming discord servers and
destiny watched it on his stream but I
imagine that the New York Times probably
just found it through those channels on
Twitter or I don't know how exactly they
found the video but I was just going
through my email one day and I had an
email from Kevin I had a lot of emails
from a lot of journalists at that time
but the New York Times is the one that I
went with for the exclusive on that so
for people who are not familiar with
your story you became radicalized to the
far right heavily influenced by some of
these echo-chamber
algorithm recommended rabbit holes that
exist on online can you talk about sort
of what your life situation was at the
beginning of this in other words because
with so often radicalization goes hand
in hand with certain particular life
circumstances at the time that someone
is vulnerable to that radicalization so
what was going on in your life when you
started to get pulled into this rabbit
hole yeah so just the brief summary is I
come from like a kind of a lower middle
class not even middle class like an
upper lower class background
and so I didn't have a lot of money I
failed out of college due to like
depression and then I hopped around a
little bit but then I ended up back at
home in West Virginia and at my
grandfather's house and it was really
just really depressed and beaten up and
I'd been told in high school that I was
bright that I was going places that I
was going to do all these great things
and then none of that stuff happened and
quite the opposite happened and I was so
depressed that like I was literally
laying in bed all day
only getting up to use the bathroom and
eat and I went to youtube to try to fix
myself off basically and when you go to
youtube to fix yourself what is the
first thing you start searching for that
seems like it might be useful to you in
the circumstances you were in well I had
found a game streamer that I'd used to
watched in high school it goes by the
channel of theme wins and he had started
doing all these neuroscience videos he
did this documentary called ghada's and
the neurons and I watched that and then
I started like doing more research on
consciousness on neuroscience self-help
and I mean once the algorithm filled up
I was just clicking thumbnails and it
was from there that I found the content
creator stefan molyneux that I would
later find and so you start at the time
you're not yet familiar with stefan
molyneux but you're pulled into some of
his content based on the recommendations
from the algorithm and then what is it
that starts to happen in your mind when
you start consuming his content so first
he did give me some ten gentle benefits
right so like I started caring more
about like personal responsibility I
started caring more about honesty but
then like at the same time I was also
picking up a lot of these political
ideas that he had and in my mind the way
the way that he framed it in the way
that I absorbed it was that the
political ideologies in the self-help
went hand-in-hand that being a
traditional conservative was like the
way you had to go if you wanted to be
happy and if you wanted to like have
this actualized life that
was like this failed ideology and he was
just gonna have casual sex and be
depressed perpetually and it so it
melded well he welded those two things
together and I just absorbed all of it
that's super interesting because that's
been one of my critiques of Jordan
Peterson which is that the self-help
type stuff is both relatively harmless
and arguably mildly positive and it also
is quite uncontroversial and unoriginal
in a sense but the problem is when
people see that content as invariably
connected to the more political content
that Jordan Peterson is putting out
there which often has not even labeled
as political but it gets to the heart of
politics about individualism and
egalitarian ism and responsibility and
all of these other things that's the
danger that sometimes the cell help is
relatively innocuous but it is
indistinguishable from the politics at
least in the minds of a lot of the young
people that start getting sucked into
this stuff and if I hear you correctly
you're sort of describing a similar
mechanism yeah I mean I like Jordan
Peterson too and I found him for the
same reasons I mean I guess the way I
would put it is like it's like the sugar
that helps that red pill go down right
so they've got to have a selling point
I'd like to think it from like a
marketing perspective so there's got to
be like a hook to draw you in so let's
continue down the rabbit hole you get
into stefan molyneux and then where does
the interest go next
it's hard to tell I went from my
algorithm and it looks like what
happened and what I remember happening
is it's weird so Molyneux I would put
like in the alt light category which is
pretty far to the right in terms of like
the center but I kind of found steven
crowder and like a lot of the
conservatives next and like I found
Rubin and I was kind of watching a lot
of those guys I was listening to a lot
of stuff about free and I guess I found
it because of like the libertarianism
stuff the free-market economics and
that's why I was listening to them and
so I went from being like a libertarian
to a conservative and then from
listening to that I started later
finding content creators like Lauren
southern and Gavin and then I kind of
came full circle and was listening to
stuff again and that
was when I kind of drifted into that alt
light Civic what they would call civic
nationalism into that sort of category
and as part of what was going on I'm
curious like how established your
political beliefs were before all of
this started because what pulled you
into this from the beginning was
actually recognizing that you weren't
happy with your life circumstances and
you wanted to improve them you said fix
yourself at the beginning of our
interview how entrenched were your
political beliefs in general at the time
when I went to the right or before that
before when you first started getting
into youtubers and and eventually got to
some of the more political ones did you
identify politically as someone on the
left or were you relatively apolitical
yeah I mean I did I guess it wasn't very
well read politically but I was very
much like I went to school when I first
went to school when I first went to
college I wanted to work on helping the
environment so I did civil engineering
and I intended to transition to
environmental engineering after I got to
the the next tier of school passed the
Community College so I I was big into
that I was also really socially liberal
so I was really politically outspoken I
would get in a lot of arguments with my
Republican family but looking back I
guess it wasn't super well read and
that's why I even fell into that stuff
in the first place
so as this continues how long would you
say that you were deeply entrenched in
right-wing beliefs during this phase
that you were consuming all of this
content well it was a dip going in and
then kind of a valley and then it was
like a dip you're gonna know a rise
coming out meaning I didn't just like
find contra points and destiny and
become liberal or something so I would
say like four and a half to five years
that I was consuming that content and
seriously thinking about it and during
that time were you acting were you an
activist for these beliefs in other
areas of your life or was it mostly
limited limited to consuming the content
online
it was mostly limited to consuming
content but like anytime I had an
opportunity in my day-to-day life so
like any of my relationships and I've
chased off a lot of friends this way I a
lien Aidid a lot of people and I noticed
that people didn't want to talk politics
with me so
I had a fiancee at the time that they
talked about in the article I would push
my beliefs on her a lot I would also do
like a lot of psychoanalyzing on her cuz
that's like what Steph kind of taught me
to do so I would do that with her and
then she had a brother-in-law that I
would like argue with and he just got to
the point where he wouldn't discuss that
stuff with me so that it was mostly just
people my personal life that I would
quote unquote write a red pill so it
sounds like in a few ways this hurt
relationships in your sort of real life
but to get back to you know you said
your initial goal at the beginning was
again to improve your life other than
getting you into political beliefs that
you now realize are problematic and no
longer follow did consuming this content
improve your life in any other
measurable ways I mean I took on a lot
of the values that Steph purported to
hold right so like honestly like after
that I've always been a pretty honest
person but after that I like very much
try to stick with that I do I started
thinking about personal responsibility
in a way that I never really thought
about it before I mean to me though
these aren't things that I needed to
become a right way to figure out though
but I guess I could say that those were
some of the positive benefits but
another way all in all I just a lien
aided me from like a lot of people what
started to change when the YouTube
algorithm ultimately led you to a path
out of the right-wing believes was it
one video in particular that you
remember popped up in that algorithm did
something change in you that maybe made
you start looking for other things no no
nothing nothing made me look for
anything new and I would have kept going
down that path and now that I talked to
people further to the right I wonder if
I would have went into the national
socialist category or not I don't know
but because I was just heading down that
trajectory so I don't know what would
have happened if I kept going it was by
chance it was the fact that destiny did
those debates I thought that it was the
Lauren southern was the first video that
popped up and apparently he did a
conversation with Martin shkreli who was
somebody that I was interested in back
then and so he did a conversation with
Martin and then he didn't I
ironically he did a conversation with
the theme wins the guy that I mentioned
earlier and then he did the conversation
with Lauren so I was almost primed to
like destiny a little bit because of
those previous conversations I thought
when he had the conversation with Lauren
it was gonna be like a nice conversation
because he had such a cordial
conversation with Martin I thought he
was a right-winger and then I watched
the conversation with Lauren and he
really deconstructed a lot of arguments
that she had on mass immigration which
was my huge sticking point and then
after that I just kept watching more and
more destiny videos and then I found
contra points for dest in these videos
because of the algorithm because she did
an interview with destiny and then I
started watching her content
it wasn't until her content that I found
other people's content before that it
was all hidden behind this like curtain
on YouTube and just to make sure the
audience knows so some of the people
you're mentioning destiny is a video
game streamer who I've interviewed on
the show and as a friend of mine his
real name is Steve Bernal and and I just
saw him in Los Angeles a couple weeks
ago as people might know contra points
is youtuber Natalie Wynne who I've also
interviewed on the program who's doing
really really great work about exposing
fascism and authoritarianism and a lot
of other stuff so how long would you say
the deprogramming period lasted sort of
like from the first time not maybe that
you watched a destiny debate but when it
actually started to reach you in a way
where you were starting to reconsider
your beliefs until you considered
yourself kind of like out of the
right-wing how long was that process
well I found destiny at the beginning of
28 like the end of 2017 beginning of
2018 and then up or no yeah yeah so we
begin the beginning of 2018 so I guess
it took about like a year and a half
something like that and at the end point
what do you know what what's your
assessment of what it is that that
happened here I mean you went in and out
both in a sense as a result of the same
YouTube algorithm that on different days
is going to recommend different things
to you in a way that contains so many
variables that it's hard to for us to
even say exactly why it is that things
come up when they come up how do you see
these these several years of your life
that went one way and then a very
way it's it's really bizarre I mean even
when I was a right-wing or I would sit
and think I was like just a couple years
ago I was a lefty I'm a right winger now
this is weird but I mean they got all
the best argument so I guess they're
right I mean that's what I believed at
the time I guess it was its alienating
looking back I was looking I was
searching for something I was in a dark
place and I was searching for something
to get me out of it
and I had found something that I thought
got me out of that I also had an
addiction to YouTube something I've had
to analyze since then there's like a
draw not just to go deeper into the
ideology because there's like an
addiction to that but also just to
consume more and more content which is
which is actually really what the
algorithm is meant to do I mean a lot of
the conversations that now are coming up
about is YouTube bias to the left or to
the right and what about their internal
employee culture versus the way they
relate to regulation in the end when it
comes to the algorithm everything I see
continues to suggest to me that it's an
algorithm meant to encourage people
watching for as long as possible which
is what's the most profitable for
YouTube period yet and that's pretty
sure that's what YouTube said the
algorithms name is reinforced that's the
name of the AI that is most dystopian
thing I've ever heard by the way and
reinforced reinforced what like so yeah
that's what that's all they care about
and you know people talk about their
politics
yeah YouTube's left-leaning sure it
looks like they did do some I haven't
looked into the project Veritas thing
too much but it does look like they they
have a political bias there that doesn't
surprise me but the thing is is people
you know I've seen people say well
there's a majority it's a majority lefty
content on YouTube and it's not really
if you're counting the the late-night
call you know the late night shows then
sure but for a long time when I was in
that space and we used to brag about it
that YouTube was dominated by
right-wingers it was all right wing
craters that I was watching and even the
bread tubers that I found later they
haven't been around for that long
I mean kat blaque and you people like
you have been on YouTube for a while but
it's mostly it was mostly dominated by
the sargon of akkad x' and the
News & the Southern's and the gavin's
and the other thing also though caleb is
that we have to be able to say okay
you're doing a where you're looking at
what what is the content that's on
YouTube and how is it doing there's also
the reality that a company's internal
culture does not necessarily tell us as
as a corporate entity what the political
biases are mean on the one hand yes
Google has rules about diversity and how
LGBT people should be treated and it all
sounds so lofty but at the same time
Google's part of the surveillance
industrial complex and working with
government in ways that I don't know any
progressive that would I would say those
are progressive values as an example
when it comes to anti regulation or
quote regulating ourselves as I recently
spoke about with Joe Rogan so it's also
important when we have those
conversations to really say what is it
that we're assessing when we measure how
many left versus right wing channels as
opposed to what are the corporate
priorities of Google or YouTube these
are all important conversations but
different ones yeah exactly yeah that's
a good point I mean to me I think that
Google's corporate priority is just to
make money I don't think they're trying
to push people in a particular direction
I just think it's about money at the end
of the day make sure if you have not
read the article in The New York Times
to read it the making of a YouTube
radical we've been speaking with the
subject of that out article Caleb Cain
who runs the YouTube channel Faraday
speaks Caleb really appreciate your time
and you talking to me today and I'm glad
you got out of of the valley as you
called it yeah thanks man yeah and I
just real quick what we're working on
right now is we have a discord server
it's very experimental but we're trying
to show idea the other side to these
people that have kind of flown into this
rabbit hole and to give them emotional
support to kind of pull them out and how
can people find that so you can find
that if honestly if you go to my YouTube
videos and go into the link there's a
link in the description to the discord
channel it's called Faraday fam or in
discord but if you just go to any of my
youtube videos at Faraday speaks on
YouTube you'll find the link into the to
the discord in the description of all
videos all right thanks so much Caleb
thank you David